Alors, il y a Étienne qui aimerait que tu lui valides une semaine de congé début août.
- Mais Étienne ça fait un an qu'il est dans la boîte ?
- Ouais.
Ben il part pas en vacances.
Autre chose ?
Heu bah si ça c'est non... Non.
Et t'oublies pas la réu à 19 heures !
*discussion houleuse*
*Comment ça tu as posé un jour de congé ?*
Je suis désolé, j'avais posé ma journée aujourd'hui.
*Ça va être long ton truc ?*
Non, ça va pas prendre longtemps, promis !
*Tu reviens direct après !*
D'accord, ok !
Quand j'ai fini je repasse au bureau.
*Oui, tout le monde t'attend là !*
OK, à toutes.
Bonjour ?
Bonjour...
Raphaël tu t'es transformé ?
Quoi ? Non, moi c'est Yacine.
Non, parce que moi j'attends quelqu'un comme toi mais c'est pas toi, c'était mon pote...
et c'est toi qui est là...
Moi j'attends Cyril.
Moi c'est Maximilien.
Je peux voir ton téléphone ?
D'accord, c'est un bug.
Moi je pensais parler à mon pote Raph' qui devait m'aider à déménager aujourd'hui.
Ah donc c'est pour ça ! Cyril ne m'avait jamais parler de déménagement...
Désolé de t'avoir dérangé, je vais me démerder... pour mon truc.
Du coup tu as besoin d'aide ?
Non, non. On se connaît pas, tu ne me dois rien....
T'inquiètes je vais trouver... Je peux déménager tout seul.
Encore désolé !
Non, pas de soucis. Bon courage !
Ça ira plus vite à deux.
T'es sûr parce que sinon...
Tu m'inviteras à manger ? Par contre cet après-midi je peux pas, il faut que j'aille au taf.
Pas de soucis, c'est déjà super sympa.
- Yacine c'est ça ?
- C'est ça !
Enchanté Yacine !
- Enchanté Maximilien.
- Tu peux m'appeler Max.
Et alors, tu fait quoi dans la vie ?
J'ai monté ma boite, je développe un jeu mobile.
Oh, sérieux ? Un jeu ? Putain mais c'est trop
...épuisant !
Il n'y a pas d'ascenseur mais on s'y fait au bout d'un moment.
Oh, c'est très sympa chez toi. Enfin ton ancien chez toi.
Et ton jeu c'est quel style ? C'est genre Candy Crush ?
C'est un jeu de stratégie et en même temps un peu narratif. C'est un peu compliqué et puis c'est pas du tout terminé.
Faut que tu me montres !
Tu as encore une Super Nintendo ?
Ouais, avec deux manettes, des jeux... J'y joue de temps en temps
Oh...Qu'est-ce que j'ai pu jouer à ce jeu...
Et toi tu fais quoi dans la vie ?
Moi c'est beaucoup moins fun que toi. Je travaille dans les ressources humaines dans une banque.
C'est déprimant.
Non mais je sais très bien ce que c'est, avant j'étais ingénieur dans une boîte d'informatique
mais bon monter sa boîte c'est super chiant aussi
entre les charges, la paperasse, les assurances, le comptable...
Estelle ?...
Ah oui... ce sont les affaires de mon ex...
Donne-le moi je vais m'en débarrasser.
Ah, tiens.
- C'est quoi ?
- C'est mon jeu, mais c'est que le début.
Yes ! Merci.
Oh, je suis désolé... En même temps c'est ton jeu... Il est trop bien !
Faut vraiment que tu le termines !
Merci beaucoup.
Tu as fait ça tout seul ?
Depuis deux ans ouais.
On y retourne ?
Allez, on y va et franchement c'est pas si dur, quelques cartons...
Si tu veux abandonner, tu peux toujours !
En même temps j'avais prévu de m'inscrire à la salle pour pousser de la fonte, donc euh...
Autant pousser ça ! Allez...
Et ça fait combien de temps que tu es dans ta boîte ?
Là ça fait cinq ans...
Je suis rentré stagiaire après évidemment j'ai eu le CDD, un CDI et maintenant je gère une petite équipe.
T'as gravis les échelons quoi.
Ouais enfin... toi tu bosses pour toi, moi je bosse pour un gars
qui m'a demandé de revenir à 14 heures alors que j'ai posé un jour de congé aujourd'hui.
Un gars qui ne se rend pas compte que ça fait genre cinq ans que j'ai pas posé une seule semaine de vacances.
Moi j'ai plus de copine, si ça peux te rassurer !
Le frigo, tu le laisses là ?
Vu le poids, je pense pas qu'il aille très loin...
Pas bouger !
J'ai pas mis assez de scotch...
T'es sûr de ça ?
T'inquiètes c'est léger, c'est des vêtements !
C'était pas des vêtements...
Saloperie de bug Facebook...
J'suis désolé...
Bon, on a bientôt fini en même temps...
Allez, go !
T'en veux ?
T'avais pas vidé le frigo ?
C'est pour ça que c'était aussi lourd ?
Je suis désolé !
Ça y est c'est officiel ! Je suis fan ! Il me faut la suite... Il me faut la suite de ce jeu.
Merci.
T'as reçu un texto.
Il dit "Ok pour ce soir."
Patron ?
Mon ancien patron. On doit voir un truc ensemble...
Putain ! Il est 14 heures !
Ah oui ton taf...
Merci Yacine,
t'as vraiment assuré, c'était vraiment super chouette et puis euh...
c'était un plaisir de te rencontrer.
Bonne...
Continuation...
Et bonne chance avec ton taf...
J'y vais pas !
Je suis en congé aujourd'hui.
Oui...
Alors il peut attendre demain !
Ouais,
J'ai pris ma journée pour ton déménagement alors il va attendre demain !
Comme tu veux...
- Tu vas pas déménager tout seul ?
- Non.
Bon. Alors on finit ?
- On y va !
- On y va ?
- Allez go !
- Go !
*Musiques*
*Ce rêve bleu...*
*C'est un nouveau monde en couleur...*
- Bah quoi ?!
- Qu'est-ce que tu vas faire ?
- C'est quoi ton problème, je déménage !
Viens, viens !
Oui je viens ! Qu'est-ce qu'il y a ?
Oui, on y va, on y va...
*C'est interdit de croire encore au bonheur...*
*Ce rêve bleu ! Je n'y crois pas c'est merveilleux !*
*Un jour, je serai le meilleur dresseur...Je me battrai sans répit...*
On a bien calé les cartons ?
Heu... Non.
Rien que pour l'ascenseur, je kiffe ton nouvel appart' !
T'as pas tout vu...
Et voilà mon nouveau palace.
Ah ouais... c'est...
C'est de la merde...
J'allais dire intimiste !
D'la merde
Pourquoi t'as quitté ton ancien appart'?
Parce que j'ai plus les moyens
comme j'ai financé mon jeu de ma poche, et puis je vis sur mes réserves donc je me retrouve ici.
Heureusement tu vas bientôt le sortir ton jeu. Comme ça tu pourras prendre plus grand !
- Je ne pense pas le sortir un jour ce jeu en fait...
- Quoi ?
J'ai perdu beaucoup trop de temps, j'ai plus d'argent...
Je suis même pas sûr que les gens s’intéressent à mon jeu alors il y a quelques jours j'ai pris ma décision
j’arrête le désastre.
- Ça veut dire quoi "J’arrête le désastre !" ?
J’arrête mon jeu.
Quoi ?!
Je peux plus continuer, je suis fauché, avec ma copine on s'est séparé, là je déménage...
J'ai une opportunité, mon ancien patron veut bien me reproposer du boulot.
Je peux pas refuser et c'est pour ça que je le vois ce soir.
Attends, tu déconnes ? Tu peux pas abandonner maintenant, alors que tu as fais le plus dur !...
Mais Yacine, tu vois bien que j'ai plus le choix !
Bien sûr que si tu as le choix !
Ton jeu, il est mortel ! T'as qu'à le sortir !
Attends, c'est quoi ? C'est un problème de thune ?
Si c’est ça, je t’accompagne à la banque et je t'aide à monter un dossier pour un crédit !
C'est gentil mais j'ai essayé...
On peut même le faire dans ma banque tiens !
Bon...
Tu sais quoi ? Si t'abandonnes...
...moi aussi j'abandonne.
Finis le tout seul ton déménagement !
Non mais Yacine...tu peux pas...
-T'abandonnes ! Du coup, je m'en vais !
Yacine...
Je m'en vais... je vais prendre le métro, j'ai un abonnement. Je peux j'ai une carte.
- Mec...
- Oui désolé...
- Ok  ! D'accord.
- D'accord quoi ?
Tu vas finir ton jeu ?
Oui.
Alors pourquoi j'ai pas entendu ?
Je termine mon jeu !
En fait, je suis loin j'entends pas
JE TERMINE MON JEU !
VOILÀ ! C'est ça qu'on veut voir
C'est ça qu'on veut entendre. D'ailleurs, file ton jeu...
Connard ?!
T'as dit "Connard" à mon patron ?
Ton ancien patron !
C'est toi ton propre patron !
Comme ça maintenant, t'as les idées claires ! T'as plus de doutes...
Allez !
- On termine !
- T'es fou...
Tu me remerciera plus tard !
Tu rêves de dire ça à ton patron à toi, c'est ça ?
Peut-être...
Ça fait plaisir au moins ?
Oui !
Oui c'est petit ! Mais... tu mettras moins de temps à traverser ton appartement !
Ah ouais... Du coup, je vais développer mon jeu plus rapidement, il sortira plus vite.
Exactement !
On se rend pas compte de la chance qu'on a !
Petite partie ?
Oui !
"Le bug de Facebook est désormais réparé..."
Attends, tu peux remettre les infos ?
"...problème, et bien c'est son propre créateur, Mark Zuckerberg,
qui est derrière cet énorme dysfonctionnement. On rappelle que le patron de Facebook a été évincé par les différents actionnaires,
et en partant, le patron a laissé une surprise... Les profils d'utilisateurs qui ont le même âge, et les même goûts,
ont été échangés. Explication : "J'ai voulu créer des rencontres entre des gens qui ne se connaissent pas."
Désormais, le bug est ..."
Oh... Il a craqué...
Donc on est pas les seules victimes...
Je vais pouvoir t'ajouter en ami sur Facebook maintenant.
Ouais !
Et, prendre une bonne branlée aussi !
Tu penses que je vais perdre en fait ?
Non, c'est très mignon de ta part mais...
Regarde...
- Tu sors du...
- Oh qu'est-ce que tu fais là ?
Ça va un peu vite !
Merci d'être venu ! Ça me fait super plaisir !
Tu rigoles, c'est pas tous les jours qu'on lance un jeu !
Je te présente Marie.
- Salut !
Enchanté Marie.
Par rapport à ça, je le mets dans le salon ou dans la cuisine ?
Oublie, c'est au même endroit en fait !
Ça va ?
Ouais et toi ?
C'est mignon chez toi !
C'est trop petit...
Mais bon... c'est chaleureux on va dire !
Au fait, on va partir en vacances avec Yacine...
C'est vrai ? Enfin !
Il a osé demander à son boss et ça fait des mois qu'on en parle...
On part dans un mois.
Félicitations...Vous me raconterez ?
Je suis trop contente...
Tu sais, il a beaucoup changé depuis qu'il te connait...
Faudrait que je le remercie parce que...
Beau score !
...si je lance le jeu ce soir, c'est un petit peu grâce à lui...
Plus qu'un clic et c'est deux années de travail qui se retrouvent en ligne...
J'y vais ?
Allez!
Bah vas-y !
Allez... 5 !
...4 !
...3 !
...2 !
...1 !